[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر اخواني
بتحيه فلسطين
تحيه القدس قط هي بلد السته مليون شهيد ان
الجزائر لم
تغير من مواقفها المبنيه على مبدا الحق
الشرعي في تصفيه الاستعمار وتقرير المصير
واقامه دوله فلسطينيه كامله
كما ان الجزائر لن تفوت اي فرصه
للتنديد بجرائم الكيان الصهيوني
واعتداءاته المتكرره على ارض فلسطين
[تصفيق]
لا لا
ويمنح ايضا لي السيد وزير المجاهدنا وذوي
الحقوق
[تصفيق]
لي ان احيي الجزائر الذي رفضت التطبيع
جمله وتفصيلا ولا تساوي مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه وتؤكد ان هذا الاحتلال ليس لا
مجال باي حال من الاحوال ان يتم التطبيع
فيه ثانيا اثبتت التجربه ان الاحتلال
يستفيد من هذا التطبيع لاهدافه وليس
لاهداف الامه العربيه وبالتالي من هنا انا
اقول على الدول العربيه التي طبعت ان تعيد
حساباتها